I spoke to you one month ago are we
better off or are we worse off the truth
we're significantly better off we have a
drug that now works it's significantly
shortens hospitalization and lowers
death rate that's this drug Graham
disappear if I was to call my doctor and
say I think I have covered 19 and they
tested me and I had it he put me on that
drug and it would reduce my symptoms the
clinical trial versus a placebo and
people who were short of breath so they
had significant viral load when they
started this dramatic effect the hope is
you treat earlier it's even more
dramatic effect you know if I gave you
Tamiflu when you were knocked out with
the flu it would do very little but if I
give it for you when you just start it
can eliminate you're getting sick the
government is predicting 3,000 people
would die by June and yet when I hear
you talk it's almost like well gee why
are those people gonna die yeah yeah why
are they gonna die REMS it's not a magic
cure-all
it lowers the death rate and it shortens
hospitalization by four days but it's
not a magic Shura at all hopefully some
of the newer drugs behind it will be
even better but yeah this virus is going
to go through the summer hopefully it'll
stay under control as we let people out
of the stay at home orders and I'm
worried about that
but the real hope is gonna be that
vaccine that's what we're pinning
everything on better drugs and a vaccine
will enable our shoulders to come even
more down and us to really be
comfortable here do you think if you get
this thing you can get it again there is
no documented case of somebody getting
it twice yet in China they showed that
the levels of immunity they have a test
there for immunity and that in the
people who are mildly or asymptomatic
immunity of those went down very quickly
so we worry about that but there's no
evidence yet for reinfection when I go
for a walk I wear a mask you know one of
these little paper masks or something
can I wear that multiple times or should
I change at each time you can wear
multiple times and the simplest way to
do it is to have a cloth mask but you
can wash every day remember so just
degrades this virus very quickly do you
think this will be possibly we're like
let's say we could go visit family
members and things like that do you see
that happening in less than a year yeah
I mean in June we'll know if these
vaccines have a high likelihood are
working we're gonna get initial data and
then you know our government to its
credit is actually starting to make
the top five vaccine candidates and then
spending all the money now in case one
two or three of them work so they're
basically saying hey listen we're not
gonna wait to see who works and then
make it we're gonna choose the top five
science and start to do production now
so we have tens of millions of doses in
the fall and more going into the winter
we could vaccinate the country you've
answered a lot of questions and I and I
thank you for that I also recommend that
people get this text every day from dr.
reyga's he gives you some message of
hope I'll give you the number three one
zero two nine nine nine three two two
you get a text about the latest trends
in health and you get regular updates
from him and thank you for taking the
time to do this I appreciate it doctor I
guess you know I do and I love you